♪
>>REE-SPEECH HEADING LIBALS
OKING UP NEW WAYS WITH
ELONUSK.
THATENING THE BIIONAIRE
TWITTER MANDING THAT HD TAMP
DO ON HATE SPEEC
DESPITE SK WITH THE CHGED
M WI THE HATE SPEE IS
ACTULY DOWN.
N FRANCISCO OFCIAL
INSTIGATING REPOS, TTTER
HAS SET UP SEPINQUARTERS FOR
EMPLOYEES  ITS OFFICE ANMUSK
FIRING BK,HOUGH
N FRANCISCO ATTAS COANIES
PRIDING DEBTS FORETIRED
EMPLOYEES INEAD OF MAKING RE
KIDS A SAFFROM FITN ALL.
ARE YOUR PRIITIES LONDON READ?
SAN FRCISCO IS PLANG
NGEROUS GAME.
MUSK COULD PACK UP TTTER
HEADARTERS ANDUST VED TO
TEXAS.
HE D THAT WITH TESLADID YQUESTIU
MORE CONVIENT FOR HIM,
RIGHT?HE HAS A LOT ON HIS PLE AN
SPREAD TN.
>> Jes: I KE TO KEEP MY
COMPIES  THE SAME STAT
>>ana:OU COULD SAVE LOT
OF MON ON TAS BUT ALSOEFFICIENC.
WATHINNG, TOO,
SAFRANCISCO WILLOMPL
ABOUBEDS TO RETIREPEOP?
THATS THE WHOLE ID HERE.
AND HE A PRIVATE COMNY AND
HIENGINEERS WANT TWORK
AROUND THE CLO TO Y  MAKE
IS WORK, TO TRTO MAKE THINGS
BETTER FOR T COMPA BECAUSE
THEY DECID TO STAYND PAYINGTHEM?
>> Jesse: T A LOT OF WOR
AROUND THELOCK IN
SAN FRANCISCO  CISCO.
YOU CAN BE HIGH T CAN'T EEP.
>> Gg: TY SHOULD ASK HIM
FOADVI ON HOUSING,OTCONDEMNING .
JESSE, LE YOU SAID HATSPEE
IS YR FAVORITE BEA.SO I THI THED
THE'S WAYS BEEN THISIE
OUT HATE SPEECIT CAN BE
DEFINED, RIG?
OPE THEOOR FOALL KINDS
OF SECH AND ES FROM -- WOR
BACKWARDS A EECH THEREATE
EECH TO SOMETHG
DISAGRABLE
SOHAT IS KD OFIF YOU AUALLY BELY
WOS AGAINST HATE SPEEC HOW
DO YOU ELAIN KYE WEST?
ERE WAS NO CSORSHIP
WHATSOEVER.
THAT IS WHY NLIGHT BEATS
EVERYTHING
IFOUANT TO SEE A BAD IDEA
E, L IT OUT.
IT IS THE ME THING WITH
BUSISSESHAT DECIDEOT T--
I DON'T KNOWALLOW SOMEBODY
INTO THEIRTORY.
LEIT HAPPEN.THE SINE DIES.
TH IS HOW IT WORKS.
T THE MAIN POINT IS, PEOPLEST VT
SPEECH PRACTICAT THE MOST.
ADAM SCHF HADELIBERATELY
MISLED ARICA ABO ACCUSED
CRIMINITOF TRUMP AND
TRP-EEYORES HOW S THATOT
HATEPEECH?
IST HE PUTTING MUSINARM'S
WAY, RIGHT BTALKING SONEGAVELY?O
ME A TIME YOU CRITIZE ARE
PUTTG SOONE IN HARM'S Y.
SO ADAM SCFF DS PUTTING MUSK
INARM'S WAY.AND MAYBE M PUTTINAT
IN HARS WAY.
D MAYBE YOU ARPUTTING ME IN
HARM'S WAY.
>> Jesse: IFOU SAY PCILNECK, HEE
SPCH.
>> Jnine: BUT IT IS A TR
DEFENSE.
>> Greg: NICE.
>> Jesse: WH DYOU THINK --
>> Jeane: EN I WAS A, WE
HAD VESTATORS IN MY OFCE
AND 40, 50 OF THEM.WE HAVE A WI.
WE WERE ON WETAP 2SAP,
SATURDAY, NDAY TALKING TEACH
OTHER.
WE H IN THE INVESTIGATORDIVISIOO
REST F AHOUR UNTIL THE WIR
WE OFFTHEY WLD DTHAT
E SAME WH MU.
WERE N TALKINGBOUT
VIOLING E ORDINANCE OFHE
CITY OF N FRCISCWHERE HE'S INTE.
PEOPLE ARE TAKG SLEEPING BAGS
AND WANT TO T A W HOURS OF
SLEEAND GO RIG BACK TO WK.
HE'S PVIDI A LITTLE MORE
MANE ABILITY A MOR
COORTABLE CHANCEOR TM TO
DO THAT.
AS FOR THE TTTERND HATE
EECH AND ALL TT STOP, LOOK,
THE FACTS E THTRUTH AND IF
ELON MK ISBLE  SAY, HATEHATE SP.
IT IS PRIVE COANY.
AD SCHF AND THE REST OF E
BUS HAVE NO RIT INRFERING
WITH THE CPANYAM I RIGR
ONG,AROLD?
>> Jse: IS SHE RIG OR
SHE WRONG,AROLD RD?
>> Jeanine: LELLY?
>>arold: THEHAVE EVERY
RIGHT TO SAYT  BEHF OFAMERICANBT
WORKPLACE.LOOK, I WA TO REE WITU
IN LAR PAR
ARE YOCOMI TO ME?
[LAUGHR]
ON MUSK AND WEAVE BEFO
ON THE SHOAND SAID I THINKJO COD
HE AS THREE OPLEN MY 52 YEAR
FE OF LITERALLREVOLUTIONIZED
SO MANY THGS ITHE WAY WE ARE
ABLE TO DO THIS.
HIS IDEAS ARFULL
IMINATION AND INNOVATION
AND OFTEN TIS TH SEEOUT REACH W,
NONSTA SPOORED ROCKET SHS.
HEAS AN AIOMPA HAS
INVEST IN THAT FNKLY HAS THEPOTE
BEFIT  THE DOUBT.
M I WILL GIVE M E BENEFIT
OF T DOUBT AS HE TES TO DO
TH, TWO ASONS, ONE, HE IS A
PITAST.
THONLY W HE WILL MAKMONEY
IF AERTISERS KEEP ADRTISING.THE.
IFHE MARKETPLACEHINGIT IS
TE SECH, PEOPLE WILL NOT
ADVERTISE E PLATFORM.
HE WAN TDO BIG THINGS WITHTHE PO
MAKE IT TH TECH PLATFO,
FINANCL TE PLATFORM AND E
HE IS AE  DO TH ANDCERTAINLPUHE
LINE OF REGULATIONECAUVERNMENT .
I LL ERYBODY TAKA CHILL
LL WITH THIS G.ADAM, MAYBE HASOU
T THERE SO FAR.
TAKE A RESAIN AND LET HIDO ELON.
WEAVE CLEANER TWITTE AND
TO ME MY TWITTER, ILL HAVE
A HEALTHIESOCI MEDIA
PLATFORM IWE L HIM DO HIS
JO
>> Jesse: ULD PUVINC
MAHON IN THAT OUP  GREATENTREPR.
IF YOU LOOAT YR SOFTWARE WWE
MPAR TO THE OTHE